I recently said in a video that the
Orville was dead
I may have spoken too soon welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
Channel on holiday on a very gray and
miserable day in North Wales
[Music]
so in a very recent video I told you
that conversations between Hulu and
fuzzy door the company that Seth
MacFarlane owns the company that
produces the Orville had ended Hulu had
basically told Seth that they didn't
want season four of the Orville so I
said effectively that ends any chance of
a new series
well I've been talking a bit further
with the source that told me that now
this sauce is a legal person they
represent one of the interested parties
in this and they were actually in the
room when Hulu basically told
representatives of fussy door that this
was the way it was
so
they know a little bit about what's
going on
he says that he's had conversations with
other people since then people at fuzzy
door Etc and he says Seth MacFarlane is
not willing to give up on the Orville
just yet now that shouldn't really
surprise us we know that this really was
a pet project for Seth that he
desperately wanted to do a Star Trek
Style Show so the Orville was what he
could do they were not going to let him
do Star Trek so he did his own version
and for many years actually it was the
best Star Trek non-startrack show on TV
so he isn't willing to give up on it
just yet but he is busy as I've said
with other things the Ted TV show The
shrouded College he's got a Star Wars
project and so on and so on
so when he's gonna when is he gonna find
time for this I'm not sure but he isn't
willing to give up and he is looking for
a new home for the Orville now I spoke
to my guy and he's basically said to me
that there's a couple of possibilities
here but we are wandering into his
opinion rather than actual leaked
information
he's basically said in his opinion the
first place Seth MacFarlane will
probably look is the peacock Network
peacock are already doing the shrouded
college and they're also doing the new
Ted show for Seth MacFarlane or with
fuzzy Dog Productions so it would only
make sense to cement that new
relationship and actually put the
Orville there as well now
fuzzy door Productions owns the IP for
the Orville so if Hulu and potentially
Disney who are the other possibility
possible suitors for the fourth season
of the Orville if they don't pick up the
option for the fourth season they are
perfectly within their rights according
to my source to look for other partners
so the peacock network is the most
obvious initial partner but who else
well apparently Netflix would be very
interested in something like this and so
would Apple now my source says he
doesn't really think that's very likely
he does think the peacock network is the
most likely but it's very early doors
so
what do I think
I'm absolutely gutted by this news that
Hulu isn't going to be picking up the
fourth season I'm not surprised I would
have thought even with the strikes Etc
something would have been announced by
now if they were going to renew the
series you have to remember that even
though the writers are on strike
produces managers directors etc etc art
and lots of other projects are being
announced
and canceled on an almost daily basis
the reason why even though Hulu told
fuzzy door apparently over a month ago
that they weren't going to be picking up
the fourth season of the Orville is
simply because they're still hopeful
it's going to happen just on a different
network
so nobody's talking about it because
nobody really knows what's going on
so the possibility is that the Orville
might not be dead after all
and I'd love to know exactly what you
think about it so get in the comments
is this a show that really really needs
a fourth season
lots of you think it does lots of you
are not so interested
so get into the comments and tell them
exactly what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com Sidetrack
where you get to see most of our new
videos first and for a small fee every
month that really supports the channel
and you get a free gift you get to see
them without the adverts as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]